on voit les trois amendements identiques
491 1099 1149 donc avis de sagesse de la
Commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
adopter et le suivant tombe
nous passons à quatre amants faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur Brisson 246
247 248
merci Madame Présidente nous adamons
parler tout à l'heure les locations de
meublé de tourisme qui sont
considérablement développés dans toutes
les zones touristiques en lien avec le
développement des plateformes de
location créé de réels problèmes en
quelques clics vous louez vos bières et
vous bénéficiez davantage fiscaux bien
plus intéressants que si vous louiez à
l'année résultat le stock des logements
loué à l'année s'effondre car il est
plus facile et plus avantageux de
pratiquer la location saisonnière créant
dans cet interrupteur une véritable
crise du logement bien entendu ces
activités qui n'ont plus rien à voir
avec la location quelques semaines de sa
résidence principale ou secondaire Andre
également concurrence directe avec les
hébergeurs professionnels qui se qui
sont déstabilisés c'est amendement
propose donc de rétablir une concurrence
plus juste et plus équitable il vous est
pour cela demandé d'exclure les
personnes qui donnent en location au
moins trois meublés de tourisme des
avantages fiscaux
issus du régime du micro BIC il y a pas
que les exactement forfaitaire de 71% ou
50%. l'application de ce régime
d'abattement forfaitaire se voulait une
mesure de simplification dans les faits
c'est devenu un amplificateur des
locations de meublés touristiques dans
les zones ou des difficiles de se loger
ce qui entraîne la réduction du parc
locatif de longue durée voilà pourquoi
c'est un mandement propose que les
personnes nous l'ont au moins 3 meublés
de tourisme déterminent leur assiette
fiscale selon le régime réel comme cela
est le cas pour des professionnels de
l'hôtellerie je vous invite donc les
chers collègues à voter cette
abonnements qui donnera un outil parmi
d'autres vous avez voté hier
l'harmonisation de la suggestion à la
TVA pour maîtriser le développement des
locations saisonnières et décourager
certaines pratiques qui menacent la
capacité des plus modestes de se loger
dans les territoires touristiques
monsieur Brisson vous avez défendu un
seul amendement parce que là vous en
avez quatre
c'est très bien c'est parfait
tout simplement donc
le second de mort propose la même chose
mais en le limitant
au
limitant au territoire
de chercher vous m'avez perturbé madame
la Présidente
voilà alors si vous si vous voulez bien
c'est abandonne-moi au vise lui aussi
inscrire du régime des abattements
forfaitaire de 71% ou 50%, les personnes
qui donnent en location développée et
tourisme mais seulement situé dans une
unité
urbaine figurant sur la liste publiée
par l'Insee voilà pour ce deuxième
amendement qui est plus limité sur les
zones
urbaines publiées par l'Insee et qui
est donc le même objectif il s'agit bien
de limiter
l'occasion saisonnière en des excluant
du régime des abattements forfaitaire de
71 ou 50% mais les personnes qui donnent
en location des meublés de tourisme
situés en zone tendue dont nous avons
parlé beaucoup cet après-midi enfin le
dernier amendement
propose le même objectif mais
en maintenant simplement ces abattements
de 71% et 50% dans les zones de
revitalisation rurales alors ces trois
amendements correspondent à des débats
qui ont eu lieu à l'Assemblée nationale
ou le gouvernement a fait valoir un
député de mon département que les gîtes
ruraux pouvaient être concernés donc il
s'agit de d'éviter la spéculation
d'éviter des locations saisonnières très
nombreuses qui bénéficient d'un
abattement extrêmement important tout en
essayant de le cerner par territoire
pour éviter que les gîtes ruraux en
particulier ne soient concernés merci
beaucoup monsieur Brisson la vie de la
commission même la rapporteur
alors madame la Présidente C4
amendements en fait propose d'exclure
complètement du régime du microbic
certaines activités de location de
meublés de tourisme qu'il soit classé ou
non alors le 246 y vivent ils vivent les
contribuables qui mettent en location au
moins trois meublés de tourisme quel que
soit le territoire le 247
ise de manière générale les personnes
qui donnent en location des meublés de
tourisme situés sur une aire urbaine
définie par l'INSEE alors sur celui-là
on a une petite difficulté parce que
aucun critère n'est indiqué pour pour la
détermination de ces unités urbaines qui
est un peu problématique et le 248 lui
vise les meublés de tourisme donnait en
location dans des zones urbaines de plus
de 50 000 habitants correspondent et ce
qui correspond au périmètre
d'application actuelle de la taxe sur
les logements vacants et le 249 lui il
vise les meublés de tourisme dans nos
locations partout sauf dans les zones de
revitalisation rurale alors les 248 et
249 en fait viennent prévoir un critère
d'application territoriale pour un
système d'imposition qui est nationale
donc là aussi ça pourrait être
problématique donc on voudrait avoir
l'avis du gouvernement mais celui qui
semble le mieux marcher serait le 246
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
c'est un sujet majeur qui a très
évidemment à l'impact des des biens des
appartements qui sont mis en location
sur des plateformes type Airbnb ce qui
en impact majeur sur des territoires
touristiques vous l'avez indiqué ça
aussi un impact majeur d'ailleurs dans
des grandes villes comme Paris où vous
avez aujourd'hui des quartiers qui sont
totalement vidés de la vie avec des gens
qui sont rescapés dans certains
immeubles qui sont les seuls à y vivre
et qui voit toute la journée des gens
qui arrivent avec des valises qui
changent parce que en fait tout est mis
sur Airbnb avec des commerces de
proximité qui ont disparu parce qu'en
fait des gens qui vivent dans le
quartier deviennent des touristes Airbnb
et donc il y a plus la vie commerçante
de quartier donc tout ça pour dire que
c'est un sujet comprend très au sérieux
et sur lequel on souhaite avancer il y a
un certain nombre de travaux qui ont été
engagés avec l'IGF il y a eu des
missions parlementaires et on est très
ouvert aux propositions on a en
l'occurrence regardez examiné vraiment
les amendements que vous avez proposé
et malheureusement nous avons des très
fortes réserves pour différentes raisons
bon d'abord ce régime microbique qui est
un régime quand même de simplification
puisqu'il évite d'avoir à calculer ses
produits et ses charges au réel de tenir
une comptabilité
microbique c'est l'abattement c'est un
régime de simplification pour des gens
qui mettent en location il y a quand
même des gens qui mettent au location à
certains moments de l'année sans
forcément que ça défigure des
territoires donc là ça veut dire que au
1er janvier 2023 vous avez des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui basculent
tout d'un coup dans un régime où elles
doivent tenir une comptabilité calculer
leur charge calculer leurs produits etc
une fois qu'on a dit ça on peut
considérer que ça vaut le coup et qu'il
faut le faire plusieurs réserves 1 dans
les personnes ou les structures qui
seraient impactées par cet amendement il
y a pas que des particuliers qui mettent
en location sur Airbnb il y a aussi des
gîtes ruraux par exemple qui serait
impactés et on sait que les gîtes ruraux
sont évidemment importants partout sur
notre territoire et donc eux pour le
coup ça les pénalise un peu in puisque
on peut pas dire qu'ils participent aux
problèmes qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
si je prends les amendements ensuite
il y a un enjeu d'égalité de devant
l'impôt et un enjeu juridique très fort
sur le 246 en gros ils ne vise que les
personnes qui ont plus de 3 appartements
plus de trois biens elle envoie bien qui
vous visez c'est vraiment ces
investisseurs qui ont acheté plusieurs
appartements qui les mettent sur Airbnb
mais on peut pas en fait
l'abattement liée au régime microbique
il n'est pas censé
il est censé comme tout abattement
refléter les charges que vous avez et
donc en fait vous pouvez pas le moduler
selon le nombre d'appartements que
détient la personne ce serait pas
constitutionnel et c'est la même chose
pour les autres amendements puisque là
il
discrimine l'accès à l'abattement selon
la zone géographique où vous trouvez et
en fait l'abattement encore une fois il
reflète il est censé refléter en tout
cas les charges que vous avez en tant
que propriétaire c'est ça le sens d'un
abattement et donc si vous le
discriminez ou si vous le changer selon
le lieu géographique ou réside le
propriétaire ça peut être considéré
comme une rupture devant l'impôt une
rupture d'égalité devant l'impôt et donc
pour ces raisons c'est un avis
défavorable mais monsieur Brisson
vraiment que vous ayez soyez convaincu
qu'on veut avancer sur ce sujet là qu'on
va continuer à y travailler encore une
fois à travers les missions qui ont été
lancées et j'ai bon espoir qu'on puisse
aboutir à des mesures qui tiennent la
route juridiquement et qui permettent
d'être efficace sur ce sujet merci alors
madame la rapporteur
pour les quatre d'accord monsieur
Brisson
de le voter
merci
monsieur Brisson pose un sujet qui est
extrêmement important pour nos
territoires et effectivement bon je moi
je voterai son amendement mais je crois
aussi qu'on a faire un réel travail je
suis pas d'accord avec vous monsieur le
ministre il y a quand même une
territorialisation à faire nous on veut
développer le tourisme en milieu rural
et je crois qu'effectivement là de
favoriser le fait de l'implantation de
de location touristique en milieu rural
doit être de nos sujets par contre
évitez que effectivement des locations
saisonnières enlève du logement
principal parce que il y a une avantage
fiscal là-dessus c'est aussi une
discrimination face à l'impôt dont je
trouve que c'est important que nous
travaillons sur ce sujet
j'aurais bien aimé qu'on garde au moins
un des amendements sur les ZRR par
rapport mais bon monsieur Brisson a fait
ce choix là j'espère qu'on continuera à
travailler sur ce sujet
merci alors je mets au voile amende oui
monsieur le ministre
bon puisque je veux montrer ma bonne
volonté de travailler non mais attendez
je vais être clair à ce stade ces
amendements ils ont été examinés ils ne
tournent pas juridiquement pour autant
on peut essayer de retravailler de
revoir mais si on se rend compte que
c'est manifestement inconstitutionnel je
le dis clairement dans la navette je
pense qu'on le on le supprimera et à ce
moment-là celui qui aurait peut-être le
plus de chance ça serait le 246 donc je
lui donne un avis de sagesse et je donne
défavorable sur les autres
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
[Musique]
nous nous relierons justement quand tu
de la méthode qu'a proposé
le ministre le sénateur et bien à cet
amendement sachant que il y a une
enceinte dans laquelle on peut faire
progresser les choses assez rapidement
puisque un groupe de travail a été mis
en place par la secret d'État à la
ruralité par le ministre du Logement
spécifiquement sur cette dimension qui
s'est réunit la semaine dernière et donc
je pense que il faut battre le fer
pendant qu'il est chaud faire en sorte
que ce groupe de travail puisse voilà
s'emparer et faire progresser le débat
dans les dans les jours qui viennent un
point puisque Viviane Artigalas évoquait
le rôle des territoires ruraux et le
rôle de l'hébergement au sein des
territoires ruraux il faut avoir en tête
que les meublés dans les territoires
ruraux ont aussi été une chance et une
opportunité parce que hélas nous avons
été un certain nombre à avoir vu
disparaître l'Auberge du Cheval Blanc
voilà et que on a perdu énormément de
lit n'a été territoires ruraux et que du
coup ces meublés sont aussi une réponse
et donc
là où parfois il y a une hyper
concentration et notamment en zone
urbaine
et on peut comprendre qu'il y a un
besoin de régulation en revanche il faut
avoir en tête que ces meublés sont de
véritables chances pour faire revivre
des destinations rurales qui avaient
perdu énormément de lits énormément
d'hébergement donc je pense qu'il faut
avoir cette nuance dans le débat parce
que là où ça pose des problèmes en
revanche dans d'autres endroits dans
d'autres territoires ça peut être aussi
des opportunités
merci alors je vais mettre au voie donc
l'amendement 246 car reçu un avis de
sagesse de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui contre qui
s'abstient il est donc adopté
l'amendement 1109 madame la triste se
compta
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre à la hausse des prix que les
ménages subissent depuis plusieurs mois
vient